bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour clichés
or notre cliché l'émission où on examine
les clichés qui servent à débloquer les
clichés en biologie évolutive
aujourd'hui on dit c'est que la notion
danse être mises en situation
on regarde la presse annonce la
découverte d'un nouvel ancêtre de
l'humanité
pas du tout c'est un ancêtre voyons
c'est un cousin se sont en paléontologie
retrouve jamais d'ancêtres c'est
possible oui il y en a pas n'existe pas
voilà et puis les cousins
alors pourquoi la notion danse être
détesté à ce point là en biologie
évolutive et bien la première raison
c'est déjà le registre fossile lui même
on ne s'attend pas à ce que toute la
série d'ancêtres et de descendants
fossilise notamment pour la série
d'évolutif des homininés et la deuxième
raison pour laquelle les évolutionnistes
sont un peu allergique à la notion dans
c'est très bien c'est qu'elle nous
renvoie à une idée linéaire de
l'évolution cette bonne vieille chienne
du progrès où on voit l'être humain se
transformer en fin de voix le chimpanzé
se transformèrent en êtres humains
voyageront donc par les danses être
évidemment ça nous renvoie une ligne et
d'ancêtres à descendants donc à la
vision linéaire de l'évolution humaine
mal alors que deux jours on parle plutôt
de buissons peugeot lui qui exactement
on préfère l'idée de but sonne ans
l'idée d'un arbre malade avec plein de
branches différentes et des espèces qui
ont coexisté
[Musique]
mais évidemment si on vous en parle
c'est que c'est pas si simple que ça en
effet si vous reprenez déjà la simple
idée de ligné et bien il faut bien
admettre que vos parents avaient des
parents que ses parents avaient des
parents eux aussi et que l'on avait les
parents et d'autres parents puis encore
des parents qui étaient au final vos
ancêtres
exactement et des parents inventeuse
ceci pendant des millions d'années ce
qui nous ramène à l'époque des
australopithèques bref cette ligne est
dense être un descendant existe et elle
a quelques en quelque sorte existe
également papa tout à fait une chaîne
s'est pas tout à fait une seule chaîne
en réalité c'est plein de petites
chaînes qui sont reliées les unes aux
autres parce qu'il ya eu plusieurs
espèces mais si on suit uniquement celle
qui a conduit à l'espèce humaine moderne
ça ne fait qu'une chaîne donc finalement
cette idée de linéarité
elle n'est pas si fausse que ça selon le
point de vue qu'on adopte et maintenant
on peut parler du registre fossile la
notion d'ancêtres dans le registre
fossile évidemment ce n'est pas une
notion d'ancêtre de type c'est un
individu qui ancestrale à un autre on
parle de populations qui sont ancêtres
d'autres populations et qui sont eux
mêmes ancêtres d'autres populations et
ainsi de suite
et ces populations elle avait un certain
nombre d'individus qui ont une
probabilité non nul de laisser des
fossiles derrière eux c'est quand même
plus simple quand il ya beaucoup
d'individus dans la population en
question comme chez les rongeurs tu me
disais exactement chez les rongeurs on a
définitivement des lignes et d'ancêtres
à descendants qui ont été découvertes y
compris en europe d'ailleurs pour
beaucoup en france et donc c'est quand
même faisable de trouver des ancêtres
dans le registre fossile alors peut-être
pas dans le registre fossile des êtres
humains comme tu l'as dit il faut
beaucoup d'individus mais par contre
chez les micro-organismes et chez des
rongeurs
ça arrive très souvent qu'on ait même
pas besoin de dessiner des arbres
phylogénétiques tout simplement parce
qu'on a les lignes et on a toutes les
lignes et complète à la question qu'on
se pose non c'est de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on peut reconnaître s'être
ancêtres parce que imaginons que je suis
trop un fossile là tout de suite
maintenant
voilà là juste là où comment on fait
pour savoir si c'est effectivement le
lien entre deux autres espèces bah ça
c'est une bonne question en fait si on
avait un ancêtre devant nous traitons
capable de le reconnaître alors en
théorie oui parce que ça il s'agirait
d'une espèce en fait ils n'auraient
aucune adaptation propre c'est à dire
aucun
caractère qui serait juste à l est cette
espèce là éventuellement pourrait être
l'ancêtre d'une autre espèce
mais alors est-ce qu'on serait vraiment
capable de reconnaître qu'il y a
absolument aucune adaptation c'est
toujours plus facile de de faire la
preuve de la présence de quelque chose
que de faire la preuve de l'absence
exactement alors la notion d'ancêtres
faut-il utiliser ou faut-il pas
l'utiliser on peut utiliser le terme
ancêtres seulement quand c'est pertinent
d'utiliser le terme ancêtres exactement
il faut l'utiliser que quand on efface
effectivement quelque chose rapidement
identifié comme étant un ancêtre mais
faut-il abandonner le mot ancêtres pour
autant et ben non parce que le nom
ancêtres c'est très important notamment
quand on peut faire barrage au
créationnisme et oui parce que si vous
dites à un créationniste que les
ancêtres ça n'existe pas que croyez vous
qu'il va se dire la théorie de
l'évolution iphone si j'ai donc
évidemment les ancêtres ça n'existe pas
alors après faut voir aussi cette
allergie à la linéarité qu'on les
évolutionnistes
elle vient aussi en grande partie du
fait qu'on construit des arbres
phylogénétiques qui par construction
n'ont pas d'ancêtres donc on préfère
parler d'ancêtres communs hypothétique
mais c'est quand même de l'acadie stick
même si vous mettiez vos propres
ancêtres à vous donc votre mère votre
grand mère dans une dans une analyse
phylogénétique de type scientifique
vous n'obtiendrez pas de toute façon un
arbre généalogique
cet arbre ne retrouvera pas vos ancêtres
en position d'ancêtres les ancêtres
n'existe pas dans ces types de
reconstruction et ça ça j'ai toute une
confusion sur la nomenclature de ce
qu'on a le droit d'appeler un ancêtre ou
pas alors tous les ancêtres ne sont pas
hypothétique
au contraire il ya des ancêtres qui
existe réellement sommes nous capables
de les retrouver la réponse est
peut-être ben qu'oui ptêt ben qu'non y
en a beaucoup de chance peut-être voilà
force de chercher des fossiles on si on
me retrouve beaucoup et on en retrouve
beaucoup des fossiles d'hominidés
notamment des dents mais bon avec des
dents isolées comme on le disait arrive
le problème de la reconnaissance de
l'identification de ces fossiles
peut-on identifier un ancêtre juste avec
des dents non juste avec des dents ce
sera difficile de savoir s'ils ont pas
des caractères propres
adaptation propre à cette espèce rare si
vous avez pas restes du squelette ça va
être compliqué exactement
mais en tout cas quoi qu'il arrive par
l'est d'ancêtres n'applique pas
forcément qu'on a une vision linéaire de
l'évolution donc non sur d'ancêtres oui
oui mais faut-il en abuser elle nous non
voilà c'était clichés or not clichés on
vous remercie d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
et on vous dis à très bientôt sur notre
chaîne
salut
[Musique]